[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au nombre des milliers de spectateurs
parisiens du Palais des Sports
inconnesseur Georges Carpentier un
connaisseur qui tout comme le public n'a
pas beaucoup apprécié le combat entre
l'Américain Perkins et le Cuba Garcia
Perkins cheveux presque rapporte une
culotte à bande plus foncée que celle de
son adversaire
on attendait 11 et merveilles du duel de
ces deux grands boxeurs candidats au
titre de champion du monde des Walter
junior on attendait un combat sévère on
a vu qu'une exhibition sans grand
intérêt un combat de gentleman dans un
salon l'arbitre a même dû intervenir
pour demander aux deux boxeurs de ne pas
se moquer du public
de fait au cours des 10 rounds et Garcia
ont échangé que des pichenettes
où sont donc les grands boxeurs
[Applaudissements]
qui te double pour les Français maillots
et culottes blanches à tweetenham devant
l'équipe d'Angleterre autrement dit
c'était le match à ne pas perdre pour
avoir une chance de remporter une fois
encore le tournoi des sa nations cette
chance les Français ont l'air de vouloir
la prendre à pleine main dixième minute
de jeu attaque classique ponctué
cependant par un essai assez heureux il
faut bien en convenir
et c'est transformé de surcroît par Al
balader
mais ce n'est là que feu de paille
l'équipe de France n'est plus quel était
les années précédentes l'équipe anglaise
non plus résultat un match intense par
l'activité des joueurs mais sans grand
intérêt quant à la qualité les anglais
sont incapables d'attaquer avec
efficacité
[Musique]
premiers 3 points c'est sur un coup
franc de Will Cox qui le marque on
s'attend en définitive à une victoire
étriquée des français ce qui ne serait
peut-être pas tout à fait injuste mais
car il y a un mais le sort va en décider
autrement sur cette mêlée justement or
jeu de Fabre coup franc 3 points de plus
pour l'Angleterre la France a perdu
cette année le tournoi des Saint-Vincent
la France continue de grelotter et Paris
à son tour s'est réveillé sous un
manteau de neige et de glace
dans les rues transformées en patinoire
se déplacer est devenu une aventure et
les transports en commun n'ont jamais
autant mérité leur nom
[Musique]
de ses doigts engourdis ce peintre a
fixer un aspect insolite de la butte
promis par d'autres au rang de station
de ski
le long du funiculaire pardon du
remonte-pinte les skieurs confirmés et
les glisseurs du dimanche ont dévalé la
piste de super-mantre se donnant pour un
instant l'illusion des transports
d'hiver
l'illusion seulement vide dissipée par
l'apparition du képi réprobateur
[Musique]
15 glacées ne paraît pas avoir affecté
outre mesure le moral des pensionnaires
plus ou moins exotiques du jardin
zolologique tous semblent prendre la
chose avec philosophie il est vrai que
leur situation matérielle est plus
privilégiées car en pleine nature
beaucoup d'animaux et d'oiseaux ne
survivront pas assez longues semaines de
froid et de faim
les conséquences de cet hiver rigoureux
sont tragique pour les cultivateurs
bretons le marché au cadran de
saint-paul-de-léon évite de marchandises
et d'acheteurs 60% des choux-fleurs et
artichauts consommaient en France ont
été littéralement dévastés par le gène
ceux qui ont pu échapper au massacre
n'ont plus atteindre leur plaine
maturité une perte qui se chiffre à 100
millions de francs 6000 exploitations
agricoles sont en difficulté
[Musique]
mais le Sénégal avec sa production de
légumes en constante augmentation a
pensé à ses amis français l'initiative
personnelle a donné soudain aux envois
de vivre frais et de poissons une
extension exceptionnelle et c'est à
raison d'une tonne par jour que
l'anguste haricots verts salade et
tomates sont acheminées par Air France
en 5 heures de vol
l'expansion industrielle en permettant
la création d'emplois et souvent le seul
moyen de sortir des villages ou des
villes de leur léthargie ici c'est un
simple atelier d'une cinquantaine de
personnes qui s'installent dans un vieux
moulin et évite ainsi à quelques
dizaines de familles une pénible
migration
à Château-du-Loir bourgade de 5000
habitants ancien relais de bagnard la
fermeture d'un dépôt de la SNCF occupant
plusieurs centaines de personnes amena
une dégradation de l'activité économique
pour la redresser des usines furent
construites et mises en location ventes
formules originale qui a réussi et qui a
donné une réelle expansion à cette ville
où 800 emplois ont été créés mais à
l'heure de l'automation le problème de
la main d'oeuvre reste le problème clé
des yeux et des mains de qualité que une
machine usuelles ne peut pas remplacer
des yeux et des mains de qualité que
peuvent offrir des travailleurs sans
formation professionnelle
[Musique]
à Dijon c'est une localisation
industrielle à grande échelle que nous
trouvons installez dans le voisinage
immédiat des nouveaux immeubles où là où
j'ai une grande partie de la main
d'oeuvre disponible l'usine amena la
création d'un centre intellectuel en
liaison avec la Faculté des Sciences
centre qui forme les ingénieurs de
l'industrie électronique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désirant limiter à 2000 le personnel de
l'usine de Dijon s'est industrie
installa des annexes dans 5
agglomérations voisines comment choisir
une commune dans chaque mairie ceux qui
désiraient travailler dans l'industrie
se faisait inscrire un deuxième élément
intervenait on cherchait de la main
d'oeuvre masculine sale Beaune avec ses
12000 habitants pouvaient permettre de
la trouver
[Musique]
on désirait de la main d'oeuvre féminine
Genlis pouvait l'offrir ayant déjà réglé
par ailleurs le problème de l'emploi des
hommes
[Musique]
l'usine se rapproche donc de la main
mieux dans un rayon de quelques
kilomètres un quart va chercher les
ouvriers à proximité de leur domicile
cette expérience va donner un nouvel
essor à la vieille capitale
bourguignonne et à toute sa région
[Musique]
au bureau comme à la chasse le style
c'est l'homme dieu merci nous n'en
sommes plus au temps où l'homme
abandonnait sa voiture à des
improvisations incertaines l'homme 63
accusera donc un certain allongement
ainsi en ont décidé de les mettre
ailleurs
il aimera le par dessus pied de coque
pour le voyage il aimera les bas de
pantalon dissymétriques beaucoup plus
long derrière que devant de l'audace
encore de l'audace il portera des
chapeaux personnalisés et le soir avec
le smoking il endossera le gilet de
l'année argenté
[Musique]
aux accessoires c'est sur la Tour Eiffel
qu'ils ont eu la vedette on y a vu
fleurir des parapluies aux mains de
Michel JAZY de Marcel Cerdan junior de
judoka et d'autres athlètes une manière
comme une autre de célébrer tout à la
fois la saint Pépin et l'adoption par
les sportifs du parapluie réputé jadis
symbole de limbourgeoisement bien à tort
si l'on en juge par l'usage qu'on peut
faire à l'occasion un Gilles de la mare
et quelques autres
[Musique]
voici donc l'homme parait pour la grande
offensive de printemps et dans cette
offensive générale déclenchée par la
haute couture parisienne voyons comment
Mark born a traité dans sa collection
les rapports de la mode et de la couleur
[Musique]
beaucoup de couleurs puisque ce sont
celles du Printemps des vers en
particulier tous les Verts grinçants
acidulés mouillé avec cela une ligne
effilée quels sont les règles d'or que
Dior a suivi cette année
les grands cercles qui tiennent lieu de
chapeau sont là pour accentuer encore
cette silhouette longue et mince des
prochains cocktails
[Musique]
apparition légère aérienne pourrait-on
dire Ascott robes
de crêpes orange comme le manteau
absinthe robe et veste de crêpes vertes
citronnade tailleur de chantung jaune
citron bien sûr avec une blouse bradée
blanche
porte-bonheur en organdi blanc trois
ensemble court pour le soir et pour le
charme
pour le grand soir et pour le grand
charme des robes longues de crêpes
vertes
ou de gaz rose également brodée chez
Dior le printemps est déjà là
[Musique]